what do I done now oh I'm discriminatory
sexist racing I was a bank job I'm
raising was I know you're a stockbroker
no it was a stop road you haven't even
got your legs right lazy you haven't
even got one of your so-called problems
but you said are you having a baby sell
Mexican if you're a massive oh no as if
you own your handy holder you know I'll
be me and get one
I don't like you I've had an opportunity
so I'm Doug opportunity to say what I
watch way to this or not all right I'll
meet you I'll meet you guys how to get
me in the street well I'm not be
shouting at home now homophobia let's
just deal with the homophobes
orientation suits and so the chairman of
the UK LGBT group is here today we do my
Demeter's know but you've had weather
risotto you've had one resign know if
I'd want beside having a second I have
decided I just offered you the
opportunity you have to meet our
chairman of our LGBT patients in meeting
your chair now I have a cup of tea or
Nepal Italian